let's just fill in the natural history
of beavers so that people understand uh
what a remarkable and strange creature
this is
so we can start with family right
um
they seem to mate for life
um you've got a mom and a dad and
not very sexually dimorphic you can't
really tell the difference
um some biologists have figured out a
method you turn the beaver upside down
and you squeeze their butt and you sniff
and it either smells like diesel or
cheese
and really yeah so you know a true
Beaver biologist yeah I know the diesel
or cheese
um yeah so I can't really tell Mom or
Dad apart
um then they'll have like two to four
young ones on average uh a year and they
The Young Ones stick around for a year
or two so you've got teenagers helpers
right so some colonies can be 12
individuals or more
um and they're territorial they've got a
an area of vegetation and water that
they're managing actively
and uh
and they manage it together I mean I
guess that's what made me think about it
is you're thinking about you know this
animal intelligently building a
um a dam
it's 12 animals it's even better
intelligently building it's
intelligently collaborating on a project
in which everybody's got to do their
part right yep and there's no foreman
right and they do a lot of digging too
so so Beaver they're very graceful in
the water
um they're not graceful on land and
they're they can be 60 pounds of
slow-moving protein right I mean
anything they can would love to eat a
beaver so they flood Landscapes to stay
protected from predators uh wolves were
a big Predator
um historically yeah Bears big predator
in my area cougars are probably one of
them the main Predator aside from of
course humans now right
um and in my area the humans were a
predator for a long time too beavers
were eaten
um
so you've got this this tight-knit
family they are interested in keeping
the big kitties at Bay by flooding the
landscape right yep and
um depending on the landscape then
they'll build a structure to live in and
if they flooded the landscape all the
way to the sides of the valley
well then you know they don't breathe
underwater they they need a dry space
they'll build themselves up a lodge and
it's this freestanding mound of sticks
and mud and it has an underwater
entrance right kind of a front door and
sometimes it'll have mini cavities in it
sometimes they have kind of a mud room
like dry your feet off and then come up
to the main chamber I think I know which
Beaver thought of that
it's the mother yeah no there's no
reason no track all that mud into the
rest of the lodge yep uh I've I've
crawled up into one of these one time
and they uh they smell lovely like like
crushed Willow
um do they really yeah yeah beavers kind
of have a willowy scent
um yeah it's not the rodent scent that
triggers the human brain like oh this is
something that yep could give me a
disease that rat scent yeah I know
there's none of that there's not even an
undertone of that it's a crushed Willow
smell yeah that's great that's
surprising to me yeah but but I get it
okay so they've got the big enough
chamber for you to get in indeed yeah
and you're not tiny no not tiny you're
crazy enough to crawl into a Beaver
Lodge yeah apparently yeah so so they
have this this lovely little Lodge in in
areas that um freeze over winter they'll
pack a bunch of vegetation down in their
Pond
um as a Larder to eat off of Once the
ice forms so this is wood or woody woody
material yeah so the uh the environment
uh softens it up over time or no you
know there's there's discussion around
like uh
what it sitting in the water does right
you know
um the the main hypothesis for a long
time has just been like accessibility
when the ice forms got it right well
that certainly makes a prediction that
where the ice doesn't form they will do
less or none of it yep and we see that
kind of borne out we do okay cool yeah
um they also they uh
and kind of a knock-on effect of this
collection of wood so you think about a
rodent that's obsessively taking
vegetation from outside the stream yeah
adding it into the stream so
um just for the sake of filling this in
for people who haven't spent much time
in Beaver habitat yeah you've got
beavers will put in a investment over
what must be
weeks on a very large log right I've
seen that oh I see one big tree one big
tree so it has to be on the shore and
has to be leaning in such a way that
they can predict that it will fall into
the water enough that they can then swim
it to wherever they it's a lot easier if
it falls in the water a lot easier if it
falls in the water there's presumably
nothing they can do with a large tree if
it falls out of the water they will
utilize it
um so but they can't move it they can't
move it yeah but they'll Buck it up
um yes I've never seen that yeah that's
cool so how long a length will they Buck
is uh when you cut a
um a log into rounds before you split it
into pieces yeah so if you're making
firewood yep 16 inches right yeah and
it's funny because beaver and I don't
know why seem to prefer a similar it
looks like cord wood except for the
taper not the end you know
and you can you can spot a spot where a
tree has been felled and bucked because
there's the wood chips at approximately
every 16 inches which you would totally
if you didn't know what was going on
probably assume implied human
involvement yeah they do look a little
like somebody was whacking at something
with a hatchet right so beavers have
these these really impressive teeth they
grow continuously yeah for the beaver's
life which is true of all rodents yeah
and the front of them are orange
um which I uh from what I understand
there's like a heavy iron component that
keeps that front Dentin
um hard yep and so they're
self-sharpening yep uh these these
little uh chisels
um and it's it's impressive they they
can fill very big trees now why they
choose sometimes to fill Big Trees is
interesting you know uh beavers being
territorial they'll be managing a wood
lot if you will a riparian area of trees
and shrubs and grasses and Forbes
through their lineage through
generations
sometimes they'll pass up a tree for
many many years and then one day it's
like that's the tree
so why do they do it
well I don't have a good example of our
explanation for you know there's
something more complicated going on so
what you're saying is you see a pattern
in which there is obviously some sort of
I don't I'm not arguing it's conscious
we don't know how beaver's mind yes but
there's intentional choice to now I fell
that one and it could be that it is
managing the habitat right in other
words you liberate other trees that are
struggling to get enough light for
example by felling a big tree and that
might be the reason that that one goes
and so again this might be a
management issue of parameters that make
the habitat more productive of things
that the Beavers are eating or and
there's a whole conversation with the
plant too and the chemical defenses that
plants put out to avoid
browsers right so every plant has their
various phenolic compounds and whatever
that they're spending some budget of
energy on chemical defense so we will uh
this audience the Dark Horse audience
will have heard Heather uh and Me Talk
many times about secondary compounds
these are compounds that don't have a
function inside the the plant or the
fungus or whatever that is producing
them their purpose is to interact with
animals usually to um to poison them so
that they will move on and eat something
else so anyway and they taste bitter
right you know animals have developed
the taste of this we have evolved the
ability to detect these oh that's a
poison yeah exactly and in fact um you
know as you know you've been to the the
tropics
um and you know there's lots of things
out there that are obviously fruits but
it's not obvious whether or not you can
eat them right um but there is a trick
which is you know you take a little
fruit yeah put it on your tongue and if
it tastes bitter you don't eat that
thing and if it tastes good then you can
uh gently explore it proceed with
caution yes this trick has never killed
me yeah not yet at least not yet not yet
you being here right that is proof good
evidence that's so far it has worked
um yeah well beavers do the same thing
sometimes you'll see them nicking into a
tree you'll see like one Little Neck and
they didn't they didn't choose to cut
that tree and then you'll see three or
four necks along and then that well
somebody's coming down and and an
interesting thing too is it seems to be
you know if your plant and you're low
you're expecting more browsers and so
you're going to spend more of your
energy producing these phenolic
compounds these bitter tannins to keep
browsers at Bay but as you grow High
well that that doesn't make sense to
spend all that budget anymore on
chemical defense because you're above
the height of the grazers and browsers
and so beavers kind of come in and
um subvert that by whacking the tree
down yeah and then they'll eat all the
foil foliage in the cambium layer from
the massive tree that stops spending
money or energy energy on these on these
poisons yeah that is so interesting and
that you can watch the deer come in
everybody loves it when a beaver drops a
big tree because suddenly you have a
very sweet
uh food source sitting there
um that's mind-blowing actually no it
makes perfect sense why why defend
against the browsers if you're tall and
they exactly you but the beaver has this
other you know it's a little bit of
chisels yeah it's reminiscent to me of
the way a Strangler fig reverses the
tables on the other trees in a tropical
forest where you know in general the
problem for every tree in a tropical
forest is you start out on the forest
floor where there's almost no light like
one percent of the incident light
actually makes it to the forest floor
and you just gotta wait an awful long
time before a gap opens up right and so
most would-be trees just die of light
starvation
before they ever get a chance and
Strangler figs uh start well at least
often at the top they start you know a
bat will uh eat a fig and drop a seed in
you know a crevice and a tree that's
accumulated some dirt and the tree grows
down from above where there's plenty of
light and now it has a water problem
weirdly but
um but anyway this strikes me as that
same sort of thing where the natural
logic of the forest has been out thunk
by one creature and there are all sorts
of consequences
um for other creatures of oh well
suddenly that tree just came you know
though vibrant and alive just came
crashing out of the canopy and you can
browse it temporarily that's really cool
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and it seems
consistent with some of the observations
I've made too where sometimes you'll
walk a section and it it seems like
there should be Beaver here and you'll
see sign that beavers have moved through
but they haven't decided to settle you
know there's plenty of water it seems
like a good spot and I'm seeing lots of
green things yeah but then you go look
at the green things and consistently I
see this in areas with like heavy elk
brows or cat public land cattle grazing
brows where you you look at the the
typical plants beavers would be eating
and they've been munched and munched and
munched and munched and they've got this
kind of like dwarfed Bonsai look going
and my mind immediately says well that's
a very bitter plant right that is a
plant that has responded with toxins and
it's probably not worth the Beavers it's
probably not worth so so to our human
Minds we're looking at lots of green
stuff but yeah I feel like there's
there's this underlying conversation
between the plants and the browsers they
build a lodge pair mates for Life yeah I
didn't finish out the lodge story yeah
so so in a context where they've been
successful and they've laterally you
know across a valley wetted the system
they've got this spongy Wetland of
habitat and it's growing all this stuff
that they're eating and
um then they have to build a lodge but
if they're in a system where there's a
high Bank convenient to deep water then
they can just build a tunnel up into
that bank and it saves a lot of effort
and so a lot of times you'll also see
beavers Denning in Banks where they can
create that air pocket usually they'll
choose to den under the root structure
of some big deciduous tree to help avoid
Predators digging in on them right that
Andrew provides like this the lattice
work of wood wood bowl works against
digging Predators also sort of strikes
me as uh reminiscent of the Shoring up
of mine shafts uh yeah totally it looks
that way yeah you've got this this these
arching Timbers over a hollowed out
space I don't know what the tree thinks
about having all that activity under it
but uh they often they'll often choose
to go
do that and we see more of that in the
context of today's landscape because of
course many of our Creeks have collapsed
into these systems where you like look
down at the creek from up on the flat
which is just an unnatural thing not
normal huh yeah not in the northern
hemisphere interesting so
um
what would it look like
well so you read some of the the Old
Trapper journals right like how do we
peer back into the Misti past okay well
our Baseline for what this is skewed
what you can't go to grinnell's journals
the the naturalist who came through and
um kind of recorded what he was seeing
because that was post Beaver trapping
you know so you've got a little bit on
on trapping journals and and some of the
maps that were being produced and
you know just some of the accounts where
you'll hear about a party that would
come into come off of a ridge top and
they get to a valley and they'd spend a
day or two trying to find a spot to
cross across the valley because it's
just one Epic beavers Wetland yeah it's
just a spongy wild world and they would
find usually a beaver dam to cross and
these beaver dams had persisted in the
landscape so long that you could
actually walk horses and wagons across
these things these things were wide wow
and so deeply rooted do you have a mill
obviously you're telling me it's a
little hard to figure it out because the
evidence wasn't well preserved but any
idea how long
A History A Beaver Dam that you could
take horses and and uh yeah right like
how how old how old is that yeah yeah
well that gets into kind of
um
do these things get passed down we know
they get passed down right we've got
these families that are attending these
things
um but it's
it's not as simple as uh you know you've
got your natal family and they defend it
against all others there's many accounts
of actually Beaver families taking in
refugees even some of the early accounts
from 150 years ago there's uh this one
author Enos Mills describes this account
where uh Wildfire came through an area
and
um one of the places beavers were living
was very pitchy and the the trees were
close and it cracked all their lodges
open and it destroyed the habitat and
there's a number of like 30 beavers
living in this spot and then a few miles
away down a drainage and up another
drainage there's another habitat where
beavers are living but they've they've
successfully created that sponge that
buffered them from the fire completely
the fire got down to the water it didn't
burn we moved on and they had a
um a spot there that was working and he
tracked the Beavers whose habitat had
been completely destroyed as they went
down the stream looking for a new spot
but then turned right and went up and
over the hill at exactly the point where
it was the shortest distance to the
um the habitat that was across the Ridge
and then down and
uh join the beavers and the pond that
had survived and so you and there was no
sign of conflict like it right so so we
don't know you know how these things are
passed we know that there's these
familial ties right um we know there's
these these territories and these um I
don't know how long I mean these things
grow roots too because you think about
Willow right yeah beavers are clipping
it into little segments and they're
jamming it into these these dams that
are built of mud and Willow sticks and
then those Willow sticks root because
yeah the Willows have gotten you can you
can plant a willow from uh cutting
exactly effectively doing that yeah and
so and a dam that's only even three
years old will be starting to literally
root into the landscape
um so let me ask you so there are so
many things I want to ask you
um obviously nobody knows in that case
of these beavers who were taken in as
refugees my prediction based on what I
think I know about biology will be that
they were closely related
um sure but it's also possible that
reciprocal altruism could do it where um
the Beavers that had that piece of
habitat that had functioned
um
uh could you know if they were limited
in their reproductive rate and they
could have used the labor of more
beavers than they had it's possible it's
a little hard to imagine that because
you would think that beavers could
produce enough uh baby beavers to right
to fill up that
um that Valley but in any case something
interesting has to be there's
interesting stuff that we don't
understand there's there's a lot of
accounts of
um digging a canal to move water into a
different system to then build a dam and
flood to access like say you've got a
really great all uh stand of Aspen over
here yeah right but the stream is
intermittent there's not enough to damn
to get to the Aspen there's many
accounts of beavers they dig canals
across the landscape and they'll divert
water into an adjacent system then
utilize that water by building a dam and
then log out the Aspen Grove and again
they're doing this with no Foreman it's
like a flume yeah yeah sure yeah a canal
yeah no that's uh that's beautiful and
um you know as you probably remember
from class back in 2010 or whatever
um one of the things I'm interested in
is
ways that Evolution solves longer term
problems than you would think it could
right based on lineage selection and
Explorer modes and so anyway this
strikes me as a as a good a good case
that one might go pursue those things
and and discover that
um you know what has to be true for the
reward of you know investing in a canal
to a habitat that isn't wet enough you
know pays off well that can very easily
be true if you're dealing with a lineage
level indeed phenomenon for sure yeah
yeah and to your point about age of
Beaver Dam too
um there's this this stream called spawn
Creek outside Logan Utah and uh when you
go walk up it there's there's a number
of beaver dams and it's a very high
gradient Creek so they'll build a 12
foot tall Beaver Dam and it doesn't buy
them a lot of pond before they need to
build another Beaver right because the
the stream is steep enough that where is
it like in a low gradient valley you can
build a two foot Beaver Dam and get
acreage right right so you walk up this
stream and then you'll notice that
there's these stair steps of calcium
um in the Stream as well and they're
they're these funny things they're like
these benches of calcium
um hypothesis being those are are more
or less fossilized beaver dams the
calcium carbonate precipitated out over
a very long period of time and Aspen
being what they are that that being has
been there for a very long time and so
beavers have been there yeah
this makes some I've wondered about this
looking at uh Beaver ponds for so long
how
they it's like they are a standing wave
right and you know you have to start
thinking in terms of an equilibrium
and you have to start thinking about uh
you know I mean
um Dawkins of course uses beavers to
elucidate his concept of uh of extended
phenotype which I think is actually it's
a great concept yeah
um and beavers really are a tremendous
Exemplar of this where you know if
you're just looking at the animal you're
really not looking at the animal because
the animal is all of the consequences of
the animal that make the animal possible
Right including making its own little
Lakes right that's
um
amazing thing but if you then project it
through time and the point is well you
know a lake once made is valuable
at lineage level and a lake once made is
a way of bootstrapping your way to some
location that was
too far to be useful right the
possibilities that are opened by an
animal that can terraform and can do so
over centuries or potentially Millennia
is it's a very powerful force much more
so than you know the road from which
it's built indeed yeah and some of us
use the term Beaver as a verb sometimes
that system has been beef and beavered
yeah yeah I mean kind of Dawkins
portrayal of it the animal is bigger
than the furry thing you're seeing yep
um a system that is beavered that that
brings a lot of explanation as to how
that complex system is working
foreign
[Music]